hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Katie
du Bois so today we're gonna check out a
video from all-time tens called ten
disgusting things about the porn
industry now if anyone knows Katie uh
you know she loves porn she loves a good
porn out everything DP gang bang bang
gangbang green pie gangbang she does a
lot of gangbang kind of porn not
personally but she's into it anyway
let's watch this I like to let the
guests peek in the intros do you ten
disgusting things about the porn
industry number 10 scalpel
this dirty fetish makes two girls one
cup look vanilla-y media is specialized
in the production of scat porn that's
erotic material involving scat porn is
considered so disgusting than producing
a can lodge in prison on scat filmmaker
IRA Isaac's were sentenced to two years
in jail in the US for producing and
selling obscene videos number nine
porno injuries vigorous bedroom exercise
gives these sex athletes serious
injuries vaginal and anal terror at
daily life and in serious cases can
causing countenance male actors are less
prone to injuries the women but they can
experience a unique debilitating injury
penile fracture women on top chutes can
sometimes snap in the rekt penis $2,000
to fix left untreated achieving an
erection will become almost oh man I
will never do rain right now
jerk off dudes in some pornographic
stores adult video arcade still exists
these are private movie areas where
customers can try before they buy adult
Hulk aids originated from peep shows
little coin-operated booths which played
early 20th century pornos one of the
first was what the butler saw a
voyeuristic scene of a woman undressing
in her bedroom but today customers are
more likely to be watching explicit
movies called anal alley and bareback
mountain
once customers are previewed their movie
sex shop employees are expected to clean
up a mess number seven gangbang legend
sex with multiple partners has been
documented as far back as the Roman
times today gangbang porn features
anything from twelve to fifty men having
sex with one woman mocking or their
efforts to shock producers are always
pushing sex acts to the limit in 2004
adult film at the Sheep the world
gangbang record when she had sex with
919 men number six now watch that video
offers the name might sound cute but
flappers are responsible for keeping
porn stars in a state of arousal on set
a 10-minute flood three to four hours to
shoot and maintaining an erection or
that long can be difficult especially
with a film crew present so directors
will cool upon the fluffer to stimulate
the actors before the cameras start
rolling flutters were once an integral
part of the porn industry until 1998
when a little blue pill called viagra
was approved for the treatment of
erectile dysfunction members of the
fluffers union have been fighting a war
against viagra ever since they've been
exercising their right to stroke by
suing pharmacies of war during your
answer
number five plastic surgery porn stars
are under constant pressure to fit the
industry's beauty ideal producers expect
their female actors to get painful
breast implants because only girls with
the biggest boobs will make it onto the
DVD box cups the porn actor Elizabeth
star has some of the biggest breasts in
porn going under the knife in 1999 to
transform her F cups into deadly o cups
with a legal string implants string
implants keep growing once they're
implanted by stimulating fluid
production but doctors have warned star
that if she doesn't have a mastectomy
that her breasts will rupture and
Pillman her before incest erotica
eighty-two percent of erotic literature
is consumed by women the advent of the
Kindle has enabled a huge female
audience to invest in niche fetish
literature which they can read
discreetly wherever they are erotica
authors are now pinning up to one porn
novel a week in the new I appeal of
genre of hip knowit's
where characters are coerced through
mind control to have sex with family
members and animals titles include gay
cowboy pounded by the men who raised me
oh my god
keeping it in the house and werewolves
and tentacles Amazon bans the sale of
erotica the some naughty novels make it
onto the site by masquerading as
traditional romantic fiction and freedom
of speech laws prevent the books from
being banned outright number three sti's
69% of actors don't wear condoms when
they're making out all films as it
climactic porno scenes condoms are used
just ten percent of the time because of
this for our industry is rife with
sexually transmitted infections in 2013
a UCLA study discovered that 1 in 4 porn
stars have an STI testing positive for
chlamydia or gonorrhea chlamydia is a
serious infection that causes genital
inflammation blindness of their
american-arab elizy while gonorrhea is
untreated can cause meningitis and
lesions on the heart
number two fairly teen is the second
most popular porn search online why is
why barely legal films do so well Wow
movies feature 18 year old girls posing
as teenagers but former producers have
found ways to get underage teens on
screen not Wyatt Ruiz Koala the same age
verification standards that the u.s.
does like checking birth certificates
this means that producers can pick up
girls from other countries that have
more lenient age restriction laws
because and that is just so [__] up
number one not school
weave porn is not a new phenomenon in
the 1950s the short-lived genre of
Holocaust erotica became very popular
especially in Israel known the static
fiction these books taught sadistic
stories about Nazi imprisonment in
concentration camps and sexual violence
by SS guards titles such as I was
Colonel Schulz his prize at [__] were
big hit to a teenage boys and it wasn't
till the 60s that these publications
were finally banned by the Israeli
government for a suit
hey guys that was 10 disgusting facts
about the porn industry hope you learned
something new and if this is a sort of
video that floats your boat why Chuck
out the 10 weirdest sexual fetishes okay
the one that really shocked me was the
one about them flying in people from
other countries who are actually under
the age of 18 not okay I will never
watch teen porn again now because of
that for that team plan was like one of
the best categories now No
yeah cuz they have these like young hot
bodies if they're actually like 14 yeah
then it's like that's not like that's
not okay yeah it doesn't matter if that
chicks from another country or not I'm
from America so yeah there's the moral
standpoint but even a legal standpoint
it's illegal for me to be driven off to
that right yeah I don't know it's
illegal for them to produce it even with
girls from other countries I shouldn't
watch it though right right but you
won't get arrested if you do who I think
oh no no the moral that's the moral
that's right there's a guideline here
but I have asked at pornography well I
just thought I was like ooh that sounds
jazzy right cuz in jazz like scouting
that's not what they meant I could I
could probably get into some scat for
one nearly um
no definitely not poop freaks me out no
no poop I don't even like it when
there's like a little poop stain in the
toilet that I know a girl left there
bothers me Veronica knows that when she
goes poop
she's a [__] ninja about it I don't
know hmm I never know she times herself
to longer than two minutes are taking a
[__] it's an island huh I'm gonna do my
bathroom they're taking shape okay
hearing the fact that like some men's
penises actually get fractured that's
very scary anyway any interest I had in
mind before just went out the window
right from there
oh I'm performing yourself like being a
porn star Yeah right you know if things
don't work out no I know yeah that does
not good
me penis fracture can you know this
right that's that's too scary because
you got to keep your dick hard for a
long time like when you filmed and stuff
so I could imagine that you know like
after a while of working on it you what
you could fracture do ah what do you do
put it like a splint no no no I'm
surprised that they're talking about
gangbang porn like being such a like one
of the middle ones of life because it's
pretty popular you yeah but they're top
they're talking about and like I don't
watch game being porn so I don't really
know but it seems like what they're
talking about is like 500 to 900 oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah no not smaller not like
under 20 but like hundreds of people
when I was fifteen I saw a video I was a
hundred men fifty on one side fifty on
the other and they were all taking turns
having sex with the girl thing coming on
her I don't I don't dig it I don't think
that's sexy I was 13 yeah it's just it's
not that's not gonna turn me on really
you know you you wouldn't be into that I
would not be into that I think I don't
think that sexy what a crock of [__] no
I know you I know you didn't says porn
taking off huh
that's crazy I've seen that that's a
category on certain websites and it's
crazy this is know that there's actual I
know they're talking about the erotica
novels but it's crazy how people make
simulation incest porn I don't know if
it's real I doubt it but you know no
good that's the scary thing sometimes
you I don't know if it's real or not
yeah but it is like an age-old tale like
there are what is it the Fall of the
House of Usher is has incest in it like
there's old like sexy literature that's
I'm not into incessant no I would never
do anything with my brother or sister I
can recognize my family members as being
attractive but I have known
dier have a sexual situation
oh yeah there are some sexy-ass hot ass
i supporting my family members but i'm
not attractive that nope you talk about
booths talk about boobs
whoops what about boobs I just think
that when you get to the point of
plastic surgery where you're endangering
yourself that is way too far but if it
makes them look better in the end like
they take the gamble
totally worth it ladies if you're
watching plastic surgery is the best way
to improve yourself I mean if you're
gonna say it if you do believe that like
let's make it for men - men don't need
men are perfect woman are flawed that is
a it's Old Testament what what please
provide a quote anyway guys thanks for
tuning in to the channel if you're new
to it you can subscribe to the real
rejects you can check out Katie du Bois
it's channel and you can find us on
Facebook Instagram the events yeah no
dude you are pissing it off you can
follow us on Facebook and Twitter
yeah I have an Instagram vine and
periscope and by the way I'm going to
VidCon this week so if I'm a little late
on uploading videos or if there's not as
many that is why and let's do a shout
out let's do a shout out
Allen Williams hello Ryan right my name
is Allen Williams aka the [__] pimp one
he's got the board and he's got the porn
name good for him on YouTube I would
like to get a shout out but not until
after I give you and the other real
rejects a shout out first in just a
short amount of time my life has become
a lot more fun interesting and exciting
all because you have made some great
videos that have helped me to pull me
out of a very dark place
butt hole can be dark my friend I won't
bother with the details well I don't
want to hear the details let's just say
that I was very unhappy and well when
he/she shits on your dick it's pretty
gross but then things start to change
when I came across a video by Brandi
Price reacting a black mask trailer
number one after that it was a chain
reaction of happy in delightful moments
sally Lomonaco inspired me to strive for
a better life with her quit her job
video do this is such a cool calm
inspiring Ryan you were clearly one of
those people who are impossible to be a
bad mood when you're around can't tell
my girlfriend that in fact that's what
all you do for me it has become
impossible for me to have a stressful
day because I know that eventually I'm
gonna go online just so I can roll them
laugh with all of you so the shadow is
for you thank you the real rejects for
being the coolest and most fun people on
the Internet Alan Williams dude um that
is a delight you know you found us
through brandy and then Sally's video
inspired you that's that this cop this
made me feel good you know I'm doing
right now I'm coming for you
I am literally orgasming for you Alan
Williams right now secreting semen
because Alan you deserve the Ryan right
semen the right semen it's not always
white but it's always right rainbow
colors how do you go to the doctor
[Music]